We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. and I have been getting many voicemails
and emails like this one.
This one happens to be from the AGYEMAN, very
pleased with the recent changes to The David
Pakman Show call segments.
Take a listen to this from the man he did
in the past when you would take phone calls.
That was my least favorite part of the show.
But lately I've been loving it.
I love your international calls.
I get so excited.
I just want to say Singapore and Vienna were
your greatest calls this week.
I'm dying.
Laughing I love the international call.
Yeah.
Also, your new phone system sounds great,
but this is call it on Friday and brother.
Happy Bannigan.
All right, yes, Chillum and everybody celebrate,
I call it Hanukkah, he seemed to call it something
else, but I have been so any time we do anything,
some people become irate with me.
But we've switched our call system from a
phone system to a Web based system through
discord, at discourse, at David Pakman dotcom
discord, call quality in terms of audio quality
has gone up.
Call quality in terms of the diversity of
callers has gotten up.
We also have the ability to do more screening
of callers and have people communicate what
they want to ask about if we want.
I think it's been a dramatic improvement.
I still have some people who are really, really
mad, some who say they don't use this scored
so they can't call.
Discords free, you could just use it or not,
it's also not mandatory to call in a couple
of other complaints that now I'm not really
remembering, but people there's always a contingent
that's mad.
But I think it has been a dramatic improvement.
And we've been hearing from callers I mean,
just last week we had Singapore, we had Austria,
we had Saudi Arabia, or as Trump says, it's
Saudi.
And what else we many callers from Latin America.
So that's all great stuff.
And there's this whole other discussion, forum
on discord as well, which you can find at
David Pakman dot com slash discord on today's
bonus show.
California is proposing some new rules for
police officers where you either have to be
at least 25 years old or have a bachelor's
degree.
The idea, I believe, is that a disproportionate
number of the bad cop complaints are some
of the very young officers, often without
college degrees.
So if you say the only way to be an officer
is if you're under 25 is to have a bachelor's
degree, you could maybe eliminate that.
Now, of course, there are arguments on the
other side that this is unfairly removing
a large swath of possible officers because
of what may be an economic hardship, preventing
them from getting a college degree.
So we're going to talk about that and the
implications on the bonus.
So we will talk about the violence and arrests
at the Trump supporter rally in Washington,
D.C. over the weekend.
There was a lot of insanity.
And we will also talk about another sports
team.
This time, it's the Cleveland baseball team
which is dropping the Indian nickname.
After much controversy, we saw Washington
Redskins become, I believe now they're just
the Washington football team.
So we will talk about that and its implications
and more get instant access to this great
bonus show by becoming a member.
Join Pacman Dotcom and remember that on January
one twenty one one one twenty one.
We will have a huge membership special for
which you need only get on our newsletter
mailing list at David Pakman dot com to be
notified on the first day of the New Year
about this wild membership special.
I'll see you then.